I think a fusion of literature and
conservatives when I break the table
pragmatic common sense libertarian
conservative Tea Party philosophy and I
think I get a great shot be elected
hi I'm Ann Welch for recent TV I'm here
in Las Vegas at Freedom Fest and i'm
joined by mr. vegas libertarian himself
Wayne Allyn root the 2008 vice
presidential nominee for the Libertarian
Party and currently you want me to give
all those titles let's see i'm on the
lnc libertarian National Committee and
I'm the chairman of the Liberty National
Campaign Committee which means I'm out
there fighting for and raising money for
and speaking on behalf of libertarian
candidates all over the United States
and author of book conscious of a
libertarian correct ah last time we were
here talking you and I about two years
two years ago right you laid out a
pretty specific step-by-step plan to
become the first libertarian party
present in the united states as of
twenty twenty or twenty 16 2016 20 20
shot would be 2016 right and the first
time you can actually win would be 2020
so how later where are you in the
flowchart i think i've made more
progress that even I expected I mean
I've become a media personality I've
become a you know I don't use the word
star I don't like that word but a guy
who's in the media a lot and so in the
last two years I've seen him mad i've
done over 2,000 media interviews and i
become a regular on Fox News we just
talked about the fact that i'll be on
judge napolitano show today and you know
everything from hannity to glenn beck to
fox and friends in the morning and
martha maccallum you name it i become a
regular on Fox and now I'm discussing
the idea of my own national radio show
my own national TV show not with Fox by
the way let's not get confused where
it's wet but I won't say who it's with
but great opportunities are being thrown
my way and I think my plan all along if
I have a shot at ever being president or
say the United States Senator of great
state of Nevada either one I think would
be helped along greatly by being a radio
talk show host or a TV talk shows
building a big following building a
bigger audience building a big brand
name for libertarian conservative
politics that's what i call it i called
myself a reagan libertarian a little bit
of reagan all the good things he did and
a little bit of libertarian you know get
rid of the bad things he didn't because
he did do some bad things spending and
the wars and the drugs and all that so
you know i think a fusion of libertarian
conservatives when I break the table
pragmatic common-sense libertarian
conservative Tea Party philosophy and I
think I get a great shot of being
elected along the way but especially if
i put together radio and TV shows i
think that will build my audience and
there's a chance here because if a
libertarian is ever going to get elected
he or she better be a national icon
better be a brand name better be in the
media day and night and if you can't
raise millions because you're not part
of the two-party system then you better
get ten billion dollars of free media
time and I've got that understanding I
you know when I was an anchorman at CNBC
I understand how important media is is
the Libertarian Party getting more
traction and the current environmental
it's not the action will tea party level
what's up no I think the Tea Party is
blown by the Libertarian Party like a
libertarian party's standing still but
it's through no fault of my own because
I really wanted our party to be more
representative of pragmatic moderate
common sense Tea Party philosophy I'm
someone who understands listen I'm with
libertarians all over this country on
issues like social issues whether it be
legalization of drugs legalization of
online gambling talking about things
like abortion or gay marriage etc I'm
with them but they're not issues America
cares about I think there are
libertarians this country they're caught
in a time warp lat they think that
America cares about these issues America
cares about jobs number one jobs number
two jobs number three jobs number ten
thousand all the way through eight
million and then maybe eight million in
one or the social issues they're just
out the window and you're talking to guy
his whole career was built on you know
sports handicapping I I could make
millions of online gambling was
legalized I never discuss it because
nobody cares well lets you know Gus it's
like you know since you actually have
insight into it what has been the
practical impact both of the prohibition
of the online gambling but also the
prosecution's that we've seen recently
well the impact is a lot of angry people
there's somewhere in a bird of ten maybe
even 15 million online gamblers in the
United States so they're all very angry
if you speak to my good friend senator
al D'Amato is now the chairman of the
poker players Alliance now there's an
odd coupling if there ever was one
former US senator state of New York
Alfonse D'Amato is called senator Otto
because he was so attentive to potholes
in the road he got reelected because he
cared about people in his district that
little thing so that was a compliment
but he's not a guy you'd ever expect to
be fighting on behalf of online gambling
but he loves poker you know just like I
love betting on sports and I can never
figure out why anybody would care if I'm
sitting in my hotel room make it a bet
on the Dallas Cowboys where the New York
Yankees why does that affect or bother
anybody in the world doesn't hurt you
want doesn't affect anyone same thing
with poker doesn't hurt anyone doesn't
affect anyone but the guys and gals were
doing it love to do it it's their
passion and I guess my thing in life is
whatever you're passionate about you're
good at and and the whole goal of
government should be helping people do
things get out of the way and help
people do things they're good at they're
passionate about they love to do that
makes you happy that brings up
satisfaction levels that makes a country
happier and i would think government
would want to do that for its people but
oh no our government you know can't
stand its people our government wants to
imprison its people it wants to throw
kids in jail for smoking pot he wants to
imprison poker players who wants to
imprison the owners of poker sites you
know it wants to imprison women for
having abortions all terrible things in
my opinion and I'd like to fight them
all but the reality is at this moment in
time jobs jobs jobs and jobs now if you
could tie it in and say online gambling
will create next to 20,000 jobs worth
bringing up as a side note I bring up
online gambling medical marijuana and
things like that as a way to raise money
and i use nevada as the example the
country's brokeback how do you solve
that i think you cut taxes which brings
in more money and incentivizes business
owners like me you dramatically cut
government spending because governments
in the way and kills jobs every day best
example spend a trillion on stimulus and
now two years later 1.9 million less
people working in the united states than
before the stimulus started so get
government out of the way lower taxes
lower spending and just like nevada
legalize medical marijuana legalized
online gambling let people do what they
want to do you'll make them happier and
you will
legalize regulate tax bring in money and
therefore lower taxes for the rest of
everybody who doesn't do those things
that's my philosophy and with that thank
you very much John Allen root this has
been Matt Welch with former libertarian
party vice presidential nominee Wayne
Allyn root a reason to be thanks